it's a pleasure to meet you hi carlos
how are you doing
doing so well you know i think every
human on earth watched
end game and went yo it'll be so cool to
be part of that and here you are
in the mcu and not only that your show
was the number one
disney plus premiere has it been
everything you dreamed
i i think so i i'm so um
i feel like people are able to see more
than i am because i'm just so
like in it and as an actor usually you
know you do something and then time
passes and you're like okay you're just
like living your life
and so i'm i'm getting it from like like
my siblings and like my friends and
they're just like oh my god oh my god oh
my god
screenshots texts you know um people
connecting to me on social media so i'm
getting that from
from them and it's it's
it's so like it's just very cool that's
all i can say
is very very very cool who is the
biggest
mcu fan in your life that is
simultaneously super excited for you but
also like
badgering you for spoilers
that is a fantastic question oh
well i would think i would have to say
hmm i'd have to say my brother
um one of my brothers um my brother were
like a year apart
and so he's the one who introduced me to
comic books when i was young like
because he
collected comic books and we actually
collected marvel cars and
scrounged our money together and so he
he's all about it he's super excited
like on social media just going in
like responding to people who are like
tweet you know tweeting at me like
it's just so it's so nice um and then
he'll also say things like
yeah so what's gonna happen with this so
what's gonna happen with that and
he's very much invested and it's cute
because you know he's a grown man
so it's nice to like to see that side of
him
but this this has brought out that side
in so many of us
like it's cool to know that you liked
comics and collected the cards
going way back do you nerd out over this
stuff as well
you know to to resp to uh to give
respect to those who are
really really into it um i
i i love it anytime i have an
opportunity to watch
um you know watch a movie a marvel movie
but i have people who
who like they still are into the comics
and they know
every inch of it and so i i'm not even
on that level and
they're a great source because i'm like
you know tell me a little bit about and
they're like an encyclopedia of
information and so i i i love it
but i know there are people who are like
who are like die hard
true aficionados and i i would have to
just
yeah bow down to those things
what makes you really excited like what
is something that you actually yourself
kind of nerd out over i love food
i love food and i love to get to travel
and try new things and new foods and
yeah my love for food is pretty
it brings me such great great it's joy
it sounds intense it's intense yes yes
now i want i do want to talk about sarah
and sam's relationship because we get to
see
you know what it's like for sort of the
grounded human
aspect that's involved in all of this
crazy superhero stuff
in sarah and we see sam and sarah's
differences does she even like
that he's a superhero how does she
really feel
i think it's kind of like one of those
things where you know if you have a
sibling
um who
you realize oh wow you actually do
important things
but then you're they're your brother
your sister and so it's kind of like
that is first and foremost it's like
i i've known you all my life i knew you
way back when and then
i feel like you have moments where you
realize oh wait a second
there what they do is really important
or it means something to them
based on maybe what other people so i
think i think it's kind of like that
with sarah like
she's he is her brother first and
foremost like all the other stuff is
secondary and i think there are moments
where she's like
you know and maybe from his perspective
or like in my life like
my family's perspective like they kind
of have to remind me and then i'm like
oh yeah yeah i mean what you do is cool
but you're my brother so
you know sometimes you have to like you
know
you just have to kind of meet them you
know and just like
see them as all of who they are and not
just like
oh you're my little brother but you're a
grown man it's like oh no you
actually okay you know you have to
remind yourself
right well it's been a pleasure talking
to you i'm so happy for you i'm excited
for you and i love
what you're bringing to this series
thank you so much for your time thank
you carlos thank you